what is going on everyone welcome to the
third part of our Python matplotlib
for data visualization tutorial series
in this section what we're going to be
talking about is doing bar charts in
histograms so first of all a lot of
people confuse bar charts and histograms
a bar chart is really to basically be
like one series and sometimes you might
be comparing things but a histogram is
really meant to show a distribution okay
so those that's like the main difference
but I think usually like the best way to
kind of visualize the difference or to
learn about the difference between bar
chart and histogram is to just do it so
we're going to do that in this this
tutorial as well as showing how to
actually code these with matplotlib so
first of all what we're going to do is
we'll get the X label and the Y label
we'll just leave we'll just call X and Y
for now it's good idea just to always
have labels but we're not really too
focused on that right now we'll leave
this calling itself an interesting graph
actually will leave the legend too so
let's just make some arbitrary bars here
and so what we'll do is we'll say x
equals a list and then y equals a list
so first of all what is a bar chart
typically well you might have a name and
then something or you'll have like a
number and then something it usually is
like to kind of denote size or you're
comparing things on a bar chart usually
so first of all let's do X is equal to 2
4 6 8 10 and then Y we can just fill
these with whatever you want I'm just
going to put in just random less than 10
numbers then let's go ahead and first
let's just plot a single bar so we could
say PLT bar and then we would plot just
no different than the other plot X's and
Y's and again let's have a label and
then we'll call this bar bars 1 ok good
enough and now let's save and run that
and what pops up is this bar chart right
so simple enough we've got the bars here
there they are you should take note the
width or the thickness of the bars it's
just a little less than one but it the
alignment is just to the right of the
numbers or the left turn edge left turn
the left edge anyways is what is the
actual point okay so now let's create a
couple more bars or one more bar rather
and call them x2 is equal to a list and
y2 is equal to a list and this list will
have as being one three five nine and I
guess we'll have to do eleven then again
why to just random numbers you can copy
me if you want but it doesn't matter
and now let's do PLT bar x2 y2 label
again and we'll call these bars too now
something might not happen that we want
so let's see turns out shoot they are
all identical looking bars that's no
good so let's go ahead and close this
out close this one out and the first
thing that we want to go ahead and do is
we're going to come down to Oh first of
all I can't count in twos with odd
numbers I need something so one three
five seven nine that was responsible for
a slight gap that we had there and there
so these two were being called the exact
same or being colored the same and even
in the legend it made our legend
basically worthless so we can add
another parameter or another keyword
argument and that keyword argument now
is going to be color now color with
matplotlib is quite interesting they
have a lot of colors that are like
pre-programmed so you can write the word
blue but they also have like all kinds
of written out colors you can also use
hex colors okay and then you can use one
letter colors like so R is red B is blue
K is black since B is blue
and see is cyan and so on so we can say
color equals R and then color equals c
for cyan and then now when we save and
run that we get this graph and sure
enough both the bars are colored as they
should be and then our legend also is
just dynamically changed to fit the
actual colors that we're using here okay
so those are bar charts now we have to
show the histogram so the histogram is a
little different and usually what it's
going to do is show a distribution of
some kind so this becomes useful when
you have like an array or a very long
list of things so let's say um we'll
call this population ages and these are
the ages of some people in the
population of our utopian town so we've
got ages generally from anything from 20
to I don't know 130 let's say it's
utopia so people are living a little
longer than we're used to so I'm just
going to start putting in like random
ages here you can do whatever you want
just be careful with your distribution
just make sure you're somewhere between
um force fella Ticats
we got babies in here it's okay
just kind of put in a bunch so I'm just
going to keep putting these in but just
make sure you're somewhere between you
know one in 130 basically is all you
need one oops
130 let's do a few more I'm just going
to keep going until I basically get off
the screen
80 75-65 54 44 43 42 48 okay that's good
enough okay so you got a bunch of ages
here now the first thing that we could
do is we could just well first of all we
have to assign these to something so we
could assign these in names but that
would get really long so we will just
assign like a person ID to do these
people will say and the way that we're
going to do that is we could say
something like this we could say the X
bar right
or we could say IDs equals the value of
x for x in range of the length of
population underscore ages so that I'll
just create a list that starts you know
here basically so it'll be 0 1 2 3 4 5 6
7 8 9 and so on so that'll create some
IDs for us so if we wanted to make a bar
chart I this we would do PLT bar and
then we would do the IDs and then the
population underscore ages but this is
going to be kind of ugly so let's save
and run that just to show and you'll see
here oh well we didn't apply a label
that's why you're getting this error
here we don't you get this error because
we we're calling legend here and we
don't have where we didn't like label
the bar but that's okay we're just kind
of showing this so anyways this is your
these are your basically your numbers
and then as we go through this almost is
a decent distribution but it doesn't
really give us an idea of like you know
how many really old adults like how many
like elderly people do we have how many
like retired people do we have how many
kind of middle-aged people do we have
how many young people and how many
babies do we have going on here this
just kind of shows us basically who's
the oldest okay it's pretty much what we
get here and the ID means nothing so
this is very there's a lot of wasted
stuff going on here so we use a
histogram to kind of show a distribution
so now instead of using a bar what we
would do is we would do a histogram so a
histogram is a lot different so I'm just
gonna get rid of this whole bar thing
and we no longer need to compute IDs
it's not necessary so with a histogram
you have what are called bins and you
can think of bins like you know the
British version of a bin you know you
it's like a box okay it's the American
box and you have a box or a bin and you
throw stuff in it okay so that's the
same thing here with a histogram you're
going to have bins and the bins are
elements that kind of contain stuff okay
so you would have a 0 a 10
in 20 let's say 30 40 50 60 70 80 90 100
120 130 so this bin will contain
everything from like 0 to 9 this one
would be 10 to 19 20 to 29 and so on
okay so these are bins and then now what
we do is we plot this histogram and also
take note these are the bins so this
means we'll have this many bars right so
as opposed to having this many bars so
it can help condense data and obviously
most populations are going to have way
more people than these right we could
take this list and make it much much
much longer if we wanted so anyways
those are bins then we're going to say
PLT hist
and this is for histogram and then in
here you give the population underscore
ages and then you give the bins that
you're going to put them in and then you
give the type of histogram hist type
note the double T's there this is a bar
and then we can have another optional
and this is our width and we'll just say
this is 0.8 that way they don't take up
the whole whole bar and that's basically
it so now we can save to run this one
and now we get a little slightly easier
to read a histogram here and we've got
some overlap going on here but otherwise
see what we can see we have nobody
between 10 and 20 and then we've got you
know basically all this other stuff
going on now for some reason we've got
100 but not a 110 I must have just
forgotten the 110 here yeah so we can
just add the 110 and let's just run it
again okay so now we can see that we've
got some age groups our biggest age
group is actually between you know 40
and 50 that looks to be our largest age
group here so middle age folks we've got
a couple babies but we got no teenagers
okay so no one's in the schools right
now and and anyway so that was a little
clearer about the distribution of ages
because the other graph made it look
like somehow we had a lot of really old
seniors or something going on and we do
have a lot of seniors but actually our
biggest population here is the 42
50s so that's a histogram and then pre
before that bar chart those are the
difference between the two if you didn't
know if you have any questions or
comments up into this point please feel
free to leave them below otherwise as
always thanks for watching thanks for
all the support and subscriptions and
until next time